[Music]
thank you so much for joining us for
today's discussion on heaven on earth so
most of the evil in the world is done
with the best of intentions or so said
TS Eliot and 9/11 the guillotine and the
Inquisition were inspired by those who
thought they had the highest moral
principles many philosophers have
concluded that morality is a subjective
human invention should we then simply
encourage and argue for acts we support
and do without morality altogether or is
the authority of morality the tenuous
thread that holds society together so to
discuss this thorny issue I have this
wonderful panel with me
I have Jason Mackenzie Alexander who is
head of the Department of Philosophy
logic and scientific method at the
London School of Economics
I have Justin who is philosopher and
historian of science at the University
of Paris d-double and his recent book is
called irrationality a history of the
dark side of Reason and to my far left
is Barry Smith who is professor of
philosophy and director at the Institute
of philosophy at the School of Advanced
Study at University of London can we
kick off with you Jason is morality
necessary okay so if we think about
whether morality is necessary its first
important to get clear on exactly what
sense of necessary we mean to begin it's
I think hopefully obvious that morality
isn't logically necessary if someone is
acting immorally they are not acting
inconsistently it's not a logical
impossibility for people to violate the
principles and rules of morality it's
also I think important to realize that
when we talk about whether morality is
necessary we don't mean physical
necessity if we think about the rules
and principles of morality it's not as
if they are somehow written into the
fabric of the universe so that it's
physically necessary that people when
they behave
morally are following those physical
requirements in the same way that when
people follow the say the law of gravity
that they are following those physical
necessities rather when we think about
whether morality is necessary we I
believe we should approach this from
thinking about it
from the point of view of whether
morality is practically or pragmatically
or prudentially necessary that is
whether morality is necessary in order
to have a well-functioning society that
is harmonious well ordered well
regulated and enabling people to achieve
what it is that they want to achieve
given the constraints placed by everyone
else so if that's the way we understand
the question of whether morality is
necessary then I would say yes morality
is necessary in the absence of morality
we would effectively find ourselves
living in a state of nature where every
person's particular interests wants
desires and preferences run the risk of
clashing and conflicting with everyone
else's what the rules and principles of
morality give us is a way of trying to
mitigate those conflicts that exists
when people try to achieve what it is
that they want or desire or see realized
so morality then is necessary in order
to try to achieve social cooperation to
try to help encourage altruism and to
try to help people behave in ways that
effectively convert a problem of
conflict and a problem and a conflict
that could turn into a war of all
against all of people trying to realize
what they want at the expense of other
people too instead a social environment
where we can all work together to try to
achieve what we want with the benefit
and not at the expense of other people
Dustin what do you think is morality
necessary I agree with Jason's opening
gambit that there is certainly no
logical or physical necessity I'm not
quite sure we can say that it is not a
question of incoherence of a kind of
logical incoherence when people fail to
act rationally but maybe we can come
back to that later I think that morality
is best seen as a particular inflection
of or let's say given society's
conception of what morality is is a
particular local inflection of some sort
of natural evolved capacity and we can
see this inflection much as it's often
been said of natural languages that
natural languages are the natural kind
of expression of an innate capacity
similarly a moral system is the local
expression like English is a local or
regional language of something that is
there for all people in all times so
what is that thing that is there for all
people in all times
it is extremely variable in its
expressions there are cultures in which
it is morally compulsory to eat the
mortal remains of your grandmother and
there are cultures in which that is
abhorrent and terrible there are
cultures that and this is something that
Montaigne already in the 16th century
fully well understood that consider
cannibalism an important part of let's
say the reproduction of society and the
continuation of society from one
generation to another
and so I'm not defending what
is often to fasoli called relativism but
I do think it is absolutely important to
understand with Montaigne that morality
etymologically but also conceptually is
linked to the notion of mores which is a
pretty close synonym of customs right so
there is something we have to respect in
order to be members of the same society
but in the end it's probably not so
different from having to respect the
rules according to which you drive on
one side of the road in the UK and on
another side of the road on the
continent
perhaps we can behind these variations
upon custom that we think of as morality
find something universal but that's
going to be so to speak very very
minimum thank you for that very so I'm
standing in and I wish we had Rebekah
Roach here who would tell you something
much more careful and subtle than I'm
going to but I'm going to try and
channel some of the things that I think
Rebecca would have wanted to bring out
so so that sense of whether morality is
necessary and were wondering how to
define that the way in which we can hear
it as meaning it's kind of inescapable
there's something a little bit
inescapable about morality because when
we see people who we think are not
behaving morally we talk about them
being immoral now you can only be
immoral if there's a standard of
morality against which you're going if
you imagine the idea of non morality
it's an idea in which there's just no
set of values and no distinctions
between doing anything that counts is
right or wrong so that's not that's all
in the ballpark of of human human
condition human society we can't even
imagine what it is to live in a world in
which we don't feel some of the strain
and some of the force of these moral
binds or moral principles that we think
we should stand by now the trouble with
the idea of taking
a stronger line on morality and looking
for something universal is that one way
to guarantee universality is to think of
moral truths or moral values as
objective what do we mean by that well
objective means they're not they're not
dependent on me in some sense they're
independent of me and therefore
independent of all of us they sort of
stand there in some objective space that
that doesn't seem to then have a story
about how we engage with them because if
they are so objective and so abstract so
cut free from the things that move and
bind us and motivate us how do we adhere
to them now of course it used to be such
a system in various religious systems
you could state what the principles were
and then think you had to adhere to them
nowadays because we can compare
religious regimes we can compare them on
moral grinds and we can say we think
some of them are not morally acceptable
so we're thinking about higher standard
but the point I want to try and stress
is that to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas